So, before 1968, putting a seat built in an American car was, you know, completely
optional. Automakers basically thought safety just didn't sell.
Yeah, which I mean, sounds completely crazy to us now.
Right. But the AI industry is sort of facing its own 1968 moment right now.
Yeah. Welcome to today's Deep Dive, by the way.
We are looking at quite a stack of documents today.
Oh, yeah, it's definitely a big stack.
We've got a request for comments from the Linux Foundation, some new model testing
guidelines from OpenAI, release notes from Alama, and a trending Hugging Face model
card. Our mission today is to, well, separate what actually happened from why it
matters to you as a builder.
And the big theme here is that the industry is clearly trying to formalize how we
measure risk, right? Especially for autonomous agents like OpenAI just outlined
new safeguards for model testing.
Right, following those recent third party cyber evaluation incidents.
Exactly. And simultaneously, literally today at the Black Hat conference, the
Open Secure AI Alliance, which is now over 120 organizations strong, I should
add, partnered with the Linux Foundation.
Wow, 120. That's big.
Yeah, it's huge. And they released a request for comments on what they're
calling SAFE.
Ah, the Shared AI Findings Exchange.
So essentially, they are proposing standardized crash test ratings for
agentic AI, right? Like we're finally shifting away from the whole move,
fast and break things era.
That's the goal.
Yeah, I mean, if you are building an agentic AI right now, the SAFE framework
means you won't be able to just, you know, throw an API key at a problem and
hope for the best.
Yeah, you're gonna have to actually prove your agent can't be hijacked before
anyone lets it out of the sandbox.
Right. It forces you to build transparency in from day one.
As these agents scale, you will have to adapt your models to much stricter
evaluation environments.
So it is no longer just about task completion?
Nope, it is about verifiable cybersecurity.
I mean, I get the theory, but looking at these documents, the actual
mechanics are completely missing.
Yeah, they really are.
Like how are open AI's new safeguards?
Are these SAFE guidelines supposed to be implemented in a daily development
workflow? Do I run a linter?
Do I submit my code to a board?
We just don't have those answers yet.
We don't. And honestly, if developers are terrified of failing these new
corporate security audits, or facing vague compliance mandates, their
immediate reaction is going to be hiding their work locally.
Taking their ball and going home, essentially.
Exactly. Taking total control of the data and the inference environment
is, well, it's the most practical defense against shifting security
landscapes.
Which totally explains why local engines like Alama are seeing such an
explosion in development right now.
They just pushed release version 0.3, 2.6, C0.
Yeah. And instead of digging into the specific GitHub pull requests, the
core takeaway is they massively updated their backend engine.
Right. To optimize how these models run on everyday processors.
Exactly. And while the infrastructure optimizes, the models themselves are
getting so much more complex.
Google AI just quietly dropped their July 2026 recap header.
But the real heat right now is on hugging face.
Oh, for sure. There is a model called Deep Grove Maple Preview,
trending hard with over 330 likes.
Yeah. And I was looking at this model card and it is heavily focused
on reasoning and uses a mixture of experts architecture.
I understand Moe is powerful.
But why is this specific combination like Moe paired with local updates
like Alama, suddenly the holy grail for a solo developer
coding in their basement?
It really comes down to hardware constraints.
You know, mixture of experts models only activate a small subset of
their neural network for any given prompt.
Wait, so it drastically saves on compute.
Exactly. It saves a ton of compute during inference compared to a
dense model of the exact same size.
I see.
So when you pair that architecture with an engine like Alama that is
constantly optimizing local execution, you suddenly give a solo
builder the ability to run incredibly sophisticated reasoning
models entirely on consumer hardware.
That's huge.
It's a total game changer.
So basically, staying updated on Alama's release cycle ensures
your local inference stack doesn't become the bottleneck.
And tracking models like Maple Preview clearly signals that
Moe and reasoning capabilities are dominating open source
builder interests right now.
They definitely are.
But you know, we do need to pump the brakes on the hype for a
second, though.
Always a catch.
Right. Because beyond the trending status on Hugging Face,
the actual benchmarks or precise capabilities of this Deep
Grove Maple Preview model remain entirely unknown.
Because it's just a preview?
Exactly. It is a preview.
It is popular.
But the hard data proving its reasoning skills simply isn't
there yet.
Which leaves us with a really fascinating collision of trends
here.
As formal safety frameworks for agentic AI take shape at the
exact same time, highly capable local Moe models become
accessible on laptops.
Where does that leave you?
It's a tough spot.
Right.
If you are building the autonomous engine in your
garage, will you soon face the exact same cybersecurity
liabilities and expectations as massive enterprise
corporations?
It's definitely something to think about before you hit
compile.